Ben Shapiro actually after the election
had a tooth tweet thread that was on
this which I responded to and I think
this kind of lays it out he said last
night was not a referendum on Democrats
excellence in governance it was a
referendum on Republicans lack of
seriousness Democrats will misread this
and keep doubling down so if Republicans
get serious and drop the frivolous BS
2024 could look very different if
if culture War isn't frivolous [ __ ]
by the way it's key but it's the icing
on the cake of competent governance and
earning trust with voters see DeSantis
Ron and young and Glenn icing on a bag
of weird ain't gonna win you elections
so I did respond to Ben I'll get into it
in one second but what he's saying there
I think which is the key part is that we
can fight the culture War right I do
this show we're constantly fighting the
culture War the gender stuff the woke
stuff the race stuff
and that is a huge piece of it to
competently fight this but actually what
people want more is good governance I
really believe that at least at least on
the Republican side they want good
governance they want a simple system
that that does what is supposed to do
and doesn't do much beyond that so if
you have a good competent government
that is fighting the woke fighting the
the culture wars properly and then using
a winning message which I really believe
is pro-family and pro freedom and
pro-america then you can win so I
retweeted Ben and I expanded on this a
little bit
uh I said this seems right but we also
have to accept that probably 40 of the
electorate wants bigger government more
lockdowns and mandates higher taxes and
less control over their own lives
changing that reality isn't political
it's spiritual right this is something I
often talk about DeSantis has laid out
the blueprint for Effective governance
partnered with the aspirational message
of Freedom Dems know a certain amount of
people just want to be governed harder
at the end of the day if California
Pennsylvania New York want more of that
then good luck to them this is the
beauty of federalism if you woke up in
New York and you don't want your kids
injected during covet six make plans and
move and if all the freedom of Florida
is bothering you go ahead and move to
New York where you can pay more in taxes
and be assaulted on the subway America
with some American flags and that really
is what it comes down to and I and I
think that you know I'm talking about
the blueprint as my message today but
that concept there that you have some
autonomy over your life is the most
important thing that we have As
Americans in terms of your ability to
think and act for yourself but that you
also have some choice that this blue red
map that we have all over this country
that you know most of the states don't
move that much anymore we have our
hardcore blue ones and our hardcore red
ones but don't forget Florida was pretty
damn purple and flipping back and forth
for a long time now it is as red as it
could possibly be again Rhonda Sanders
won by 20 points actually I'll just
throw this up real quick the numbers
here on the the amount of people that
voted for Ron DeSantis he had over 4.6
million votes Chris had about
3.1 million you must remember the key
part of this is that Ron DeSantis won
his election in 2018 by less than 40 000
votes it was like 35 000 votes something
like that he almost lost that election
it was basically under one percent and
the guy that would be Governor right now
in Florida Andrew Gilliam turned out to
be a meth addict that's how close
Florida was to the precipice and then
DeSantis comes in and does it right
keeps his eye on the ball acts bravely
governs as a competent manager
and this place is working